[Musique]
les malades arrivent à l'hôpital de new
delhi entre hills
ces indiens sortent leurs frères comme
ils le peuvent ils respirent à peine à
l'entrée de l'hôpital c'est la pagaille
les malades décèdent avant d'être soigné
depuis ce matin les voyageurs en
provenance de guyaz du brésil du chili
mais aussi d'afrique du sud et d'un sont
eux priés de se soumettre à une
quarantaine à leur arrivée en france des
jours d'isolement stricte ces dernières
24 heures l'inde a battu un nouveau
record de kako vie 19 sur une journée
avec 340 mille nouveaux malades
nous avons en quelque sorte assuré
engagé la bataille contre ces variants
ces variants qui vous le savez sans
aucune menace à laquelle nous devons
nous protéger ce qui s'est passé à
rambouillet absolument ignobles et
bouleversant pour tous les français et
je veux dire mes pensées pour la famille
de la victime
quel est le parcours de djamel gore chan
le meurtrier de la fonctionnaire de
police tué au commissariat de
rambouillet
l'homme de 36 ans tunisien était
chauffeur livreur est arrivé en france
en 2009 avant d'être régularisées en
2019 une fois de plus une innocente
une femme policière a été lâchement
assassinés et qu'au fond les gouvernants
depuis bien longtemps et
particulièrement ceux qui nous
gouvernent aujourd'hui font preuve d'une
forme de lâcheté ou de soumission
voilà un personnage qui n'était repéré
par personne qu'ils n'avaient aucune
trace sur son casier judiciaire dont la
radicalisation date de quelques semaines
à peine qui n'a pas d'armes d'autres
armes et la sq un couteau c'est
extrêmement difficile
depuis 2010 est ses 36 projets
d'attentats qui ont été déjouées par nos
services
c'est un projet toutes les six semaines
ce sont autant de projets qui s'ils
avaient abouti aurait coûté la mort à
nos concitoyens
on doit pouvoir laisser une partie de la
sécurité publique la sécurité de voie
publique à des polices municipales que
je souhaite armée en tout cas dans les
grandes villes
la première chose c'est d'oser dire la
vérité il y a un lien entre
l'immigration massive et le terrorisme
alors là si vous n'êtes pas le seul à
dire le rassemblement national de di
ossi
oui
vers le disait dans les années 90 peu
importe c'est à dire la reprise en main
de notre politique migratoire et la
lutte contre le terrorisme va y venir
des landes est à l'abri de tout on va d
immigration le nombre de déclarations de
ceux qui quand il était au pouvoir n'ont
rien fait sur le sujet est
impressionnant et des réflexes que j'ai
qualifiée de vautours anna gray peine
deux heures pour aller sur les plateaux
de télévision pour twitté pendant qu'ils
aient encore une intervention sur la
scène de crime
pendant qu'on sait même pas encore si
les familles ont été prévenues ou pas
tout de suite allé dans les médias se
répandre pour intervenir
moi je parlais de marine le pen oui
notamment je trouve pas ça je ne trouve
pas ça descend le nouveau tour et quand
même pas anodin non de traiter la 6e
position s'est exprimée vis-à-vis de
telle ou telle personnalité politique
comme on le dit en rajoute et de ce
point de vue là c'est évidemment
condamnable une boule de feu qui
traversent le ciel c'était hier soir
voyait ces images filmées à cannes
une lueur provoquée par une météore le
phénomène a été observé de nice à
marseille et jusqu'à lyon le premier à
rentrer dans la station c'est win win le
manchot en peluche qui a servi
d'indicateurs d'apesanteur suivi par le
japonais akiyoshi des et enfin un thomas
pesquet tout sourire heureux de
retrouver cette station spatiale où il a
déjà passé 196 jours il ya quatre ans la
plus belle image de ce week-end c'est
bien sûr ce décollage quand la nuit
s'embrassent koehler vibre et que le
gigantesque vaisseau lutte contre la
gravité terrestre